[Music]
I reject nation Hey my good buddy
my good buddy my human body and that's
great y'all though I'm Greg Alva it's a
show well this is good intro for a best
of bad acting reaction we're going to do
today is it it is yes mm-hmm
listen guys this is one of my most
requested videos I have right now going
for the right person to do it and I
thought I need an actress who
understands what bad acting in cataratas
here what is compilation' I love that
about you that confidence is what it
takes
anyway let's check this out Kat Alvarado
has a website I wanted to tell you guys
about because she is a comedian if you
ever want to know when she's performing
there's a link in the description box to
go to her website canto brought up calm
slash events anytime she has an event
coming up it'll be updated there so I
got follow her on Facebook and
everything to spot her on social media
it's the only way I can ensure her
coming back for a cameo here yeah
otherwise there's no friendship that's
the way this works mm-hmm we call the
biz people got a tit for tat tit for tat
there's no such thing as real friendship
we grew up here it's in our blood and
through the engine
[Music]
[Laughter]
what who told you that you're lying just
to save your life
there's only one way to prove my
innocence
Oh God
trust me
[Music]
Oh God
[Music]
are you good at that is there an affair
with your wife
I don't think we should talk about it
does it protect
[Music]
[Music]
would you like to go out with me Cedric
Oh uh-huh
yes I would would you like to [ __ ] me
this is a porn feels like it
bingo well then let's see what you've
got
nothing there Greg what nothing there
that's what I show my female friends
exactly what would interest you
something the size of MU oh yeah I have
why
well you dr. mr. cut a big portion of it
off ha ha no he he was a good doctor
freedom in law the man is innocent until
he's proven guilty yes nothing on me oh
I got a lot of [ __ ] on you well I'm
telling me the son of a [ __ ] that we
respect the Japanese of this country who
are honest businessmen and yeah this is
the land of opportunity for legitimate
business not for depth merchants
he's really trying to strip your
children through schools and on the
streets no I'm telling these
[ __ ] but if they continue
killing our children to make their
precious Millions that they deposit in
their secret Swiss bank accounts okay
look before your lawsuit even gets off
the clerk's desk I'll have their
stinking bodies and garbage bags and
ship them back to Japan for fertilizer
you got it cue cards in you two
she like flirt excuse me miss by the way
what's an all-american girl like you
doing with a geek like this this is a
terrible editing C round then you just
wing it I brought up I feel like this
whole thing is samurai cop yeah that's
great
[Music]
we're directedness
[Music]
samurai caste law was crazy
Milanovic do bad you will die hey this
is my house
[Music]
allow me to introduce this is weirdly
inspiration I am created naen are you
[Music]
what happens when theater at cameras
- too much less is more
am I mistaken or is there something
wrong with the truth dr. Mitch
[Music]
they're happy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh God Oh Star Trek has come such a long
way
[Music]
you's a handsome guy
[Music]
my name is Aaron brand I always thought
I was doing the right thing and
preparing for life I was the first in my
class in college in computer science I
joined the military and became a fighter
pilot and won many medals for
distinguished service
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I get the impression he directed this
lets get better fresh same guy let's
just do it take what we do this I can't
believe you committed suicide I cannot
believe you committed suicide
how could you have done this how could
you have committed suicide I can't help
you out of this one job
[Music]
goodbye my friend did he just say it
can't help you out of this gene can I
help you yeah can I have a dozen red
roses please oh hi Johnny I didn't know
what you here you go
that's me how much is it it'll be $18 go
keep the change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot favorite guest hi mark you
are lying I nearly hit you you have
Tammy partly job no I can anyway how is
your sex life chicken feet are you just
a little chick photo with Gigi
[Music]
don't touch me [ __ ] get out
[Music]
if you tried you betrayed me you're not
good you just cheated it's not over
everybody betrayed me I fed Apple of
this world
[Music]
oh my god actually really is engaging so
clearly I have enough sense of the plot
very emotional like they had a budget
[Music]
oh well I think it should give you hope
this is great
[Music]
[Music]
2016 part to use on it
[Music]
the part two
[Music]
it's a baby
[Music]
teen which oh dude oh yeah that dancing
I'm so glad I wasn't alive that here
dear man they're into it oh that's who I
wanted to be when I was younger they
just they just still make rap like how
they used to cat oh my gosh the day's a
good old bunker behind us before we go
any further I just got to look up this
Double Down movie and see if my theory
is correct yep oh yeah the director ed
started it just had that feeling of like
only guys who want to star in their own
movies it was the same guy in fatal
finding O'Neill breed who are you I've
never heard of you before you're my new
favorite person in a weird way this kind
of gives me faith like if they got money
to do it if people back them and decided
to work with them I'm feeling no one did
he's independently wealthy and did it
himself because who would like even if
he showed like a short film somebody
like fondest like who would be like yeah
okay I guess I mean why is everyone so
bad cuz he like has his wife play his
wife and his daughters plays daughters
like how much you want to bet I would
not be surprised I mean there's a whole
plethora of these terrible films though
that make me go if these guys were able
to get this made I can at least get
something maybe even even if it's bad I
will get something made one of these
days I think we have some sketches that
are way better at quality in these
feature film say hey you know
so shocked by how horrible these are you
haven't seen the room I have not seen
the room now I'm very intrigued and I
understand the appeal I need to see this
I'm telling you the room is great what I
love about most of these bad films
there's a lot of sexual stuff in these
bad films yeah it just seems like a lot
of actor directors who are like horny
who are trying to put together something
to be around a naked woman or have sex
appeal
yep and I've never tried that and I
don't think it will work for me but if
it worked for Neil Breen what woman is
like you know what I'll do it I'll do
this horrible yeah why did they agree to
these films one step on the way to my
Oscar it's funny there's only one
genuine big movie in here and I'm
looking for a rare it is Mortal Kombat
annihilation the sequel the Mortal
Kombat other than that the rest are
movies that you'd see at a bargain bin
and be like this looks awful then you
watch you're like sure enough this is
awful can I have my hour and 20 minutes
back exactly no you can't that's how I
feel when I usually go to your stand-ups
and I [ __ ] that joke up ah damn damn
now it's definitely not funny yeah leave
the joking to me sorry
I've never went to class or you I forget
actually do I do it you do acting okay
you think you're better than this I
would hope so but you know what I think
if I had to pick one of the bad
actresses to say 'la humbly that I am
that bad is the girl from troll the one
who was like playing an old lady but she
was Ian right like that wasn't too bad I
think I would just like to theatrical
what is a tube is it wasn't too bad
because of comparison to the other
compilation that we were watching right
well it was that one with the troll lady
is like she's obviously been in a lot of
musicals and done decent job and some
Shakespeare plays festivals and operas
maybe even be like very trained but
she's like no camera training you know
thing with camera training is like you
end up having to like have less facial
expressions and then just like you act
with your eyes just like yeah oh yeah
total team theory
and I'm not a subtle person you're
pretty subtle I think I think you have
like dry humor on stage you know maybe
no look at me I'm a hyper comedian I'm a
funny woman yeah I guess I am pretty
subtle maybe it's cuz I've taken so many
on-camera acting classes that I've
become subtle I didn't know you act
I should cast you in one of my sketches
I pay with exposure
[Laughter]
I might provide pizza as far as it goes
if you throw in Starbucks all right yeah
that's gonna be a sketch and you know
not gonna do one of those sexual things
good because freaking me to ruin that
for everyone
damn it wait can we look at that troll
lady's makeup again that was Benny yeah
yeah let me find her that's samurai cop
thing that's something I want to check
out who wrote that movie this is the
same guy already hire some male model no
certainty wrote and directed it cast oh
my god my passion project to put
together the last movie directed was
samurai cop that was the nail in the
coffin right there you know what scares
me but all this stuff is like my
boyfriend is like 10 years older than me
so he was like of a decent age at this
and looking on that weird 90 stuff I'm
like oh my god that was like probably
him like he was creepy and nineties he
like that yes I get that vibe from him
too if you're watching you're a [ __ ]
pervert the perverted dork no no there's
no time for that if you think of any
other movies we're just so acting it's
so bad that it has to be seen I can't
think I thought they covered most of
what I would think Ray Daniel day-lewis
and there will be blood it talks like
that I drink your milkshake I drink your
milkshake no crap no one talks like that
alright I'm in California personalities
out here no
jocks like that you guys can subscribe
to the real rejects it might be worth
your time click that notification Belka
subscribe buttons are broken Kat
Alvarado is a very very very hilarious
comedian oh we just got into the big
blind comedy festival is this like a
thing you're making up okay yeah in case
you're wondering if I am or I'm not
fitting I am a big powerful big pine
it's in Flagstaff Arizona that's where
all great comedians good Flagstaff
actually there's a great like laser tag
spot out there with coke carts your
Flagstaff you should go there and maybe
go to her show the big what big fine big
fine comedy
it's an it's in subchapter it's a laser
house September what on 19 to 27
that's right around your birthday it is
and yours third September 3rd
ok the September 3rd